- J'ai jamais pensé que
je pouvais être aussi fier
d'être Québécois que ce soir!
(applaudissements)
- Il est disparu il y a 35 ans,
mais pour beaucoup de Québécois,
René Lévesque, le politicien
le chef d'état et le simple
citoyen, est encore vivant
et maintenant bien présent
dans l'espace public,
celui de la Place des
spectacles à Montréal.
ÉRIC LEFEBVRE, DG, Partenariat
du Quartier ecececectacles
- L'idée, c'était de faire
redécouvrir René Lévesque
aux nouveaux arrivants et
aux jeunes pour qu'ils puissent
être capables de sa
l'importance, un tout petit peu,
de sa contribution au Québec.
- Plusieurs anciens
ténors du parti Québécois
et d'autres ont rendu hommage
à cet homxcxcxcxception.
LUCIEN BOUCHARD, ancien
premier ministre du Québec
- C'est René Lévesque
aujourd'hui, comme toujours.
René Lévesque, qui est pas
emememement qu'une figure
du passé, qui est quelqu'un
de très actuel, puis on veut
l'évoquer aujourd'hui ensemble.
SIMON JOLIN-BARRETTE, ministre
resp. de la Langue française, Qc
- C'est important de rendre
hommage à quelqu'un qui a servi
le Québec durant tant d'années,
qui a tellement apporté aux
Québécois et aux Québecoises.
GILLES DUCEPPE,
c c c chef, Bloc québécois
- On a vu la carrière
extraordinaire de cet homme
humble, avec de grandes idées,
ouvert sur le monde, hein.
C'était pas quelqu'un qui
était replié sur lui-m
là, ouvert sur le monde.
- Un autre cérémonie a eu lieu
en son honneur en Gaspésie,
là où il a grandi.
CLAUDE LÉVESQUE,
fils de Renéquququque
- Ça me touche de voir que
autant de gens se souviennent
de lui, que sa mémoire
est bien.. bien observée.
- Et à Longueuil, un groupe
uiuiuiuistes a même tenu
à le célébrer en famille.
PAULINE MAROIS, ancienne
première ministre du Québec
- Il n'y a pas une semaine
où, comme députée de Longeuil,
de Taillon, on ne m'as pas
interpellée pour me dire : "Ah!
On s'ennuie de René lévesque."
- L'exposition sur René
Lévesque, qui est accompagné
d'un court métrage, lui rend
hommage mais sans verser
dans la complaisance,
affirme l'un des auteurs.
LUC CYR,
cinéaste et réalisateur
- Ce qui nous intéresse
ici, c'est particulièrement
le côté h C C C Comment est-ce
qu'un être comme René Lévesque
entre dans l'histoire en étant
ce qu'il est, c'est-à-dire
un être imparfait, a
des défauts, des qualités,
des sautes d'humeur,
des moments de dépression.
- C'est également un rappel
aux plus jeu a a a aux nouveaux
arrivants de la place
qu'il a occupée dans
notre histoire récente.
- Je crois que c'est important,
cette histoire-là, pour
qu'ils comprennent qu'est-ce
qu'on a vécu puis comment
on a dû se battre puis pourquoi
on doit continuer à se battre.
- Ça fait 45 ans que je vis
à Montréal. René Lévesque,
on peut dire que c'est celui,
la personne qui illustre
le mieux qui nous sommes,
les Québécoises
et les Québécois.
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal